British prime minister Kier starmer
decided to celebrate multiculturalism by
going on a 10K hike with a Hindu and a
Muslim perfect photo op they were
planning to stay at a hotel at the end
of the hike but about halfway through
their Journey PM starmer chipped a nail
and started sobbing
uncontrollably they kept walking but PM
starmer's moaning and wailing slowed
them down and the Hindu and the Muslim
got a bit worried because it was getting
dark and they weren't sure they'd be
able to find the hotel in the middle of
the
night fortunately just as they were
wondering if they were going to have to
sleep on the ground they came across an
old farmhouse they went up to the old
farmhouse and banged on the door banged
on the door banged on the door until an
old farmer finally answered the farmer
said can I help you prime minister
starmer replied look I can't stand
working class British losers like you
and your stupid non Posh accents but I
chipped a nail and we can't find the
hotel so could we stay here for the
night farmer says well I've got one
guest room with two beds so two of you
can stay in the guest room I don't have
room in the house for a third guest but
I've got a barn out back with plenty of
hay two-tier Kier responds that will be
Splendid then he turns to the Hindu and
says you know I am the prime minister so
I shouldn't be staying in a barn how
about you sleep in the barn tonight the
Hindu answers no problem I'll sleep on
the hay and he heads to the barn two TI
Kier and the Muslim lay down in their
beds about 20 minutes later there's a
knock on the guest room
door they open the door and who do they
find it's the Hindu the Hindu says I'm
sorry I tried I didn't want to come back
can bother you but I can't sleep in that
Barn there's a cow in there the cow is
sacred to me how could a lowly person
such as myself sleep in the presence of
such a beautiful symbol of life and
Purity and motherly love two-tier Kier
sees the problem and says I understand
and I hear you why don't you come and
sleep in one of the beds in the guest
room and we'll let the Muslim go sleep
in the barn the Muslim says mashah I'll
do it
he heads out to the barn and two tier
Kier and the Hindu lay down in their
beds about 10 minutes later there's a
knock on the guest room
door they open the door and who do they
find it's the Muslim the Muslim says I'm
sorry I tried but I can't sleep in that
Barn there's a pig in there the pig is a
disgusting creature to me I can't sleep
in a barn with a pig knowing that this
filthy vile animal that will eat
anything even its dead relatives or its
own waste is in there with me so the
Muslim and the Hindu stare at two-tier
Kier for a while until he finally says
okay okay I know I'm the Prime Minister
but I'll sleep in the barn just make
sure you tell everyone later about how I
let a Hindu and a Muslim sleep in beds
whilst I prime minister Kama went and
slept in a b two TI heads out to the
barn and the Hindu and the Muslim lay
down in their beds not even 5 minutes go
by and there's a knock on the guest room
door they open the door and who do they
find it's the Pig and the cow